every time boston dynamics puts out one
of the big youtube productions the world
is amazed the robots dance or they do
parkour all of which is very impressive
but it's under control conditions in a
lab it's not exactly a practical real
world use so what are those robots
actually being used for in the real
world
inside this mountainside in western
austria is a hydroelectric power plant i
would have filmed this piece of camera
actually down in the turbine hall but
it's a bit loud in here
at full capacity 150 tons of water a
second goes down from the uphill
reservoir through the turbines in the
cavern generating 350 megawatts of power
and it's all run remotely switching this
plant on and off is done at a control
center about half an hour's drive that
way where they also control 20 other
hydro plants on a normal day no one
works here at all but for safety someone
does have to regularly drive out to all
those 20 power plants and check that the
physical things are all as they should
be
so you can probably see where this is
going we are using a robot to
continuously do inspection tasks and
therefore testing if this is plausible
in the middle of the alps energy
robotics is putting software on robots
to make them smart we are a software
company and we're not building the
hardware we're writing codes therefore
we ask other companies to build the
hardware for us or use existing robots
already we work with a lot of robot
companies depicting the best robot for
the task boston dynamics and other
companies build the actual physical
robots and provide a remote controller
that someone can use to directly move
the bots around but they also provide an
interface for computer code the robot
has built-in navigation and obstacle
avoidance so in the same way that you
can write code to automate things on a
regular computer you can write code for
the robot dog's computer too your code
can learn the whole site that you're
working at and tell the bot okay find
your way to this point look at this
thing take a picture and a temperature
reading and if that picture doesn't look
like it should or there's something
blocking your way
let us know about it
the robot is not remote controlled
that's doing that task autonomously that
means we teach in a certain mission and
then robert does the repetition of the
mission but it also be in the future
able to do something called click and
inspect that means we have a digital
twin of the environment and then we're
just saying what the robot needs to
inspect and the robot plans to pass
towards the inspection point and get the
information the robot autonomously
extracts that information and reacts
based on the results means either it
sends an alarm if it's out of the norm
or it just collects information then put
it into the report at the end of the
mission you can send robot dogs into
toxic or radioactive environments humans
shouldn't be in but this isn't a
particularly dangerous site they're let
me in after all it's just inconvenient
to drive here particularly in winter
when snow storms might close the
mountain road entirely this is a place
designed for humans though which is why
robots with wheels or tracks aren't an
option so it's important to have a robot
which is capable to operate in human
environment because all the
infrastructure humans have built have
been built for humans so therefore we
need a robot to be capable of
interacting with this environment
meaning simply if we have a situation
like here where we need to climb stairs
we're using a robot on lags in the
substation where we have flat ground for
example using robots on wheels or on
tracks we're developing a skill which we
will use in oil and gas where many of
our robots are actually working which we
call man-down detector so that if the
robot detecting someone lying on the
ground because of whatever incident then
the robot sounds an alarm and therefore
bringing the troops to help the person
lying on the ground this trial will
succeed or fail based on two questions
first does it work reliably and second
if so is it cheaper overall than sending
out people particularly when there might
be a shortage of engineers soon the goal
is to support human inspection and on
the long run to replace certain parts
especially those where humans need to be
sent in hazardous environments in
germany we have about 8 000 substation
all of those need to have inspection and
the number of substation is growing due
to the change to renewable energy we
need to have more robots on the ground
because we have not enough engineers in
the workforce right now and we need
about 400 000 more in the next 10 years
the robot can perform up to 12 hours of
inspections 60 minutes walking around 60
minutes charging so a lot of inspection
every day so the next few years we're
also testing assistive manipulation
where the robot is with a human doing
manipulation tasks within infrastructure
environments in the future there might
be fully autonomous manipulation but
that is probably some years to go if
this works and if it gets rolled out
then the power companies will be saving
employee time and therefore money in the
same way that 20 power plants can now be
controlled from one centre 20 power
plants could be inspected from one
centre with actual human engineers
dispatched only when there's actually
something wrong that needs to be fixed
and i suspect it will be a while before
the robots start to take over that job
as well
you